here's what would happen if an AI could  produce better art than humans since we  started painting on Cave walls art has  reflected The Human Experience but soon  the human element May no longer be  required this piece of AI generated art  recently beat out 20 other entries in a  digital photography competition the AI  created a digital painting So finely  detailed that judges couldn't tell it  wasn't real  could you I read this story on morning  brew a free daily newsletter delivered  to my inbox seven days a week in just  five minutes I'm caught up on business  finance and of course Tech and it's  completely free to sign up which is  really the only way you can get me to  sign up for anything join over 4 million  people who are already subscribed and  get your daily news their extensive  archive and stories that are so much  better than the regular news since  they're not dry and boring stories like